what's going on everybody this is tyler
posey today i'm here with buzzfeed and
i'm going to be talking about my first
times
[Music]
first celebrity crush salma hayek in the
movie the desperado starring on tony
bandetz
i was like five years old when i watched
it and it's blew my mind in the movie he
walks around with a guitar case filled
with guns and my older brother played
guitar and he had an acoustic guitar
case and i would fill it with water guns
and put them in my diaper is that old
diaper they were like pull-ups you know
and i would walk around my house
shooting my family with water
first time i realized i was famous i was
at a chipotle i don't remember with who
could have been dylan o'brien could have
been probably not though and the girl
behind the counter recognized me and
then came out of the counter and gave me
a hug or i took a picture with her or
something like that but there was also
another moment when i was 10 years old
after i filmed the movie made in
manhattan and i went to six flags magic
mountain with my friends and we were on
a log ride and there were five of us but
only four could fit in a log ride so i
was like you guys go i'll hang out i'll
hang back and so i got i got a log ride
by myself which i thought was really
cool in the moment and then we were like
finished the ride and we were pulling up
to the dock i was by myself and there
was some dude older guy i was ten so
everyone was older he was like hey
you're that kid from made in manhattan
right pretty sure i was like no and i
like shrank got really uncomfortable and
nervous and that was the day my
anxieties began
the first person who believed in me
definitely my parents yeah people they
were my biggest supporters my entire
life growing up i was a weird kid i was
very creative and artistic and
you know i was an actor and a musician
or want to be a musician i would always
sing my songs to my parents i would
write yeah definitely my parents i don't
know if that's a cliche thing but they
were my biggest supporters i've heard a
lot of people in my position who wanted
to be actors or musicians when they were
kids and their parents were like you
gotta be a doctor or something else so i
didn't go through that thankfully
they rocked
and still do okay the first song that i
ever wrote i think i was about like 10
or 12 years old it's a weird song it
goes today i woke up a different person
it seems like i have no reason to live
[ __ ] up with a hundred excuses and i'm
so
goddamn useless once cool with a total
mojo no more
one two three go
i was a punk fan as a kid and still am
and so i think there was some punk
influence behind that pretty cool my
parents allowed me to cuss when i was a
kid so i started early my first music
inspiration
is a tough one there's a lot of them my
dad took me to a peter paul and mary
concert when i was a kid puff the magic
dragon and then my dad introduced me to
layla by derek in the dominoes or eric
clapton and i fell in love with that
song but definitely blink 182 is the
band that changed my life i was seven
years old when i discovered them at my
friend's birthday party and i was
bouncing on a trampoline i fell in love
with that band i think partly because i
was a kid and i was working out of the
country in canada i was by myself
basically and i just got all blank cds
dvds documentaries posters and i just
like they became my best friends
it's that sad and yeah blinkling2
totally changed my life yeah i have
travis barker played on one of my songs
just recently i did a movie with tom
delong he directed me in like a short
film and i still keep in touch with him
much to his disapproval text them all
the time what's up dude the first day on
set of teen wolf i remember it being
freezing so we filmed in
atlanta georgia it's our first lacrosse
day we were with ornie adams me and
dylan o'brien were with orny adams who
plays our coach and yeah it was freezing
and it was so cold that our lips weren't
you know when you're like freezing and
you try to speak and your lips don't
move but we're having the greatest time
we were like 18 years old like freshly
turned 18 years old and orni's this
comedian and like saying all these
really weird creepy jokes and we loved
it and you know craft service was there
you know craft service is great eating
all the food jeff davis the creator of
the show since he hired me a trainer
because you know werewolves are supposed
to be buff he would follow me to the
craft service table and be like you
can't eat that you can't eat that you
can't eat that first impressions of my
team of co-stars so i met most of them
at the audition process when we were all
still auditioning for
our roles like i was auditioning and
there was another kid auditioning for
scott dylan was auditioning for styles
there was another kid auditioning for
styles tyler heckman auditioning for
derek there's another person reading for
derek but crystal reed was the only
person that was reading for alison the
second i walked into the room i was
wearing a hurley sweater which is like a
skate surf company and dylan was wearing
a dvs shirt which is a skateboard
company it was like the first pair of
skateboard shoes i ever bought when i
was a kid and he had a buzzed head and i
was like this kid looks cool
i immediately was like all right what's
this kid's deal you know because as an
actor i grew up in a small town but
skateboarding was like the biggest thing
in that town i loved skateboard i loved
punk rock and i didn't really fit in
with other actors and so this was the
first time i saw another actor who was
like seemed like a normal kid like me
and i found out that he was you know he
grew up in a surf town and
skated with his friends and played in a
band and we fell in love that day like
we started fantasizing about like dude
if you get this role and i get this role
we're going to move to atlanta and i'm
going to bring a drum set and i'm gonna
bring my guitar and we're gonna start
skating and whatever so we really hit it
off in like a lot of ways and we we got
each other's numbers that day we still
weren't sure if we had booked this show
yet and then later that day we found out
but yeah tyler hecklin i met previously
also on another show that we did called
lincoln heights i was like hey dude
what's going on and he was like he just
seemed like this dad to me like he was
like our dad like he was already
20 years older than us even though he
was like 22 at the time or something
like that yet crystal was just you know
obviously a very pretty person a great
actress you know it was fun to like act
with her i loved them there was no there
was no no no bad one in the bunch except
for me what's up dude okay yeah so the
first friend i made on set of teen wolf
i really fell in love with the crew we
had stand-ins that we became really
friendly with um there's this one dude
named josh in atlanta he became like one
of our best friends he would always fly
out to my birthdays like we started this
tradition where he would come to my
birthday at my 21st birthday in vegas
and then we just kept he just kept
coming out and he became one of my best
friends and i have no idea what the hell
he did
i still have no idea it was a set
decorator or something like that the
first role that i really wanted and
auditioned for but i didn't get
the like original spy kids i remember
auditioning for spy kids and i didn't
get that role i'm still pissed off about
it i'm gonna call my therapist
i didn't get very far in the audience
process i remember i taped it in my it
was like the first tape i had ever done
i was in my garage i was like i don't
know i was really young i was like eight
years old or something and i was in my
garage i remember my mom was filming me
that was it we sent it in and we never
heard back from them then i saw the
movie and i was like wait a second i
said that line in an audition and then
that was the beginning of the worst days
of my life
first famous friend i made in hollywood
it was miley cyrus but i was filming in
canada so i was filming a tv show in
canada where i fell in love with blink
1882
and her dad was the star of my tv show
uh which was doc and he billy ray cyrus
and we were kids i was nine she was
eight i
befriended miley she was like the only
person my age so we would like go to
museums we'd hang out all the time write
music do stupid stuff with each other
that little kids do uh yeah she kissed
me
i remember there was one time we were
like in her house she was like do this
i was like okay
she's like no no not that
like this i was like what
and then i
you know eventually i realized that she
was like trying to make me do a kissy
face
and then she gave me she planted a big
one right on my mouth
and i loved it
[Laughter]
we were dating also it was just my first
girlfriend so yeah my first kiss i guess
technically was miley you know it was
very awkward and very young and juvenile
and cute and sweet and wholesome so
aside from that they're you know as a
kid in junior high everyone's talking
about making out you know you made out
yeah you go to the movies and you make
out there was a girl
who in like in my friend group who like
hadn't kissed anybody yet or something
like that and i was bragging i was like
i've kissed a bunch of times and i
actually at that point had never made
out with anybody this is the first time
i'm saying this uh my whole reputation
is about to be ruined right now and i
never made out with anybody but i was
like you know yeah yeah i'm making all
the time dude i made out with her i mean
i remember she was like okay well let's
do it you know i can't remember how it
started but like we were going to make
out and
we we did we did it like i went in and
we started kissing i think i got like
flushed and nervous and sorry like
pulled away but i like i think i blamed
her for biting my lip which she didn't i
was like oh gosh
so that's it so yeah i'm a fraud when
you go buzzfeed
sucks first time out of starstruck i
think was probably was either mark
hoppus backstage at a concert and i like
i was drunk and i walked up to it i was
like
tapped him on her shoulder and i was
like hey i just wanted to say i'm like a
huge huge huge fan and he's like awesome
dude one second he like turned around
and walked
i was like i was probably really drunk
and stupid no i wouldn't want to talk to
me either you know also i love you mark
oppas so much but i think also there was
a time i was doing the scream awards for
fx fox i can't remember because i was
presenting an award and i was backstage
and quentin tarantino and nicholas cage
were having a conversation with each
other and i just wanted to be a fly on
the wall so bad for that conversation
because it would have been the craziest
conversation ever but i was like i'm a
huge fan of queen tarantino and i was
like hey man i just want to say like big
fan of you he's like oh thanks thanks
man yeah tyler okay awesome very nice to
meet you it was really sweet it was
awesome first onset memory working with
jlo jennifer lopez in made in manhattan
we were in the bronx i think filming and
i was in my trailer and her trailer was
kind of across the street from mine the
big extravagant luxurious trailer and i
was in this little tin can but i loved
that tin can there was like a group of
people surrounding her trailer and also
a fire truck the firemen were on the
their pa system saying
like enticing her to come outside uh and
then i told her i remember i told her i
was like on set and i was like did you
hear the firefighters screaming your
name they're coming outside she's like
no i didn't hear that but yeah that was
a weird one there was also another time
where we got into a van with her like we
were filming and then we got into a van
and people started like rocking the van
like we had all these fans come up to
her it was crazy scary i was frightened
this poor little 10 year old boy pooping
his pants
and that was the beginning of the voice
daily
i'm still pooping my pants
thank you buzzfeed those were my firsts
and hopefully some fresh answers in
there i had a lot of fun thank you for
joining make sure you check out my ep
drugs and also come hang out with us on
tour i'm on the internet kill the
rockstar tour with mod son and
girlfriends we're all under the big
noise label come hang out wear your mask
wear your underwear please wear your
underwear and i'll see you there
you